already a winner tonight my friend how
you feeling
pretty good i'm gonna go i'm in a good
mood you're in a good mood chilled i'm
chilled i'm chilled have you had a
chance to congratulate lil nazex on your
win together
nah
i would like to though maybe i'll
facetime him in a second i just found
out but why don't you try facetiming him
right now do you have your phone on you
i don't you don't oh damn
hey gotta congratulate you on the new
album you have some heavy hitters
featured like justin timberlake now he
hasn't put out music in a minute
literally since the inauguration in
early 2021 you have power my friend
how'd you get jt
maybe it's a mutual respect thing i know
i've been on his radar for a while and
he's been on my radar my whole life so
um
something i wanted to do and he was
really open to it so i'm grateful now
you're a 90s baby like me were you
always an nsync fan growing up
you know what's crazy is
i was a little late to instinct
you know i'm 98 so like
i had to go back and do a little
research but
you know i love them bye bye bye right
right
now speaking of nostalgia you are making
your film debut and white man can't jump
the reboot playing billy have you had a
chance to talk to woody harrelson yet no
i want to i've been waiting to run into
him
i want his blessing
you want his blessing what do you want
that conversation to look like with him
um
i mean hopefully i'm like i have a
t-shirt on like some jeans okay yeah and
he gives you his blessing and it's all
smooth exactly okay now i want to throw
it back really quick to 2020. i will
never forget this instagram live you did
with doja cat where you expressed that
you had a crush on her now she's going
to be here tonight are you going to
shoot your shot
i think i'm playing it cool today
i've actually become uh
i've become cool with those you know
that was early in our friendship
now we uh we know each other pretty well
so
ain't gonna do nothing too silly okay
are you crushing on anyone else these
days or is it all about the music in the
movies and focus on the career
uh there's always a new crush
who is that
i'm just gonna chill today like i said
ah you know is someone here though that
you got your eye on
let me see
i'm right here jack just kidding
don't be wrong you're beautiful i just
you know
i uh i thought you meant somebody on
this sheet y'all got right here oh there
is egyptian you want to take a glance at
it to see who's your contenders tonight
we've got well miranda lambert she's
married let me read it don't be trying
to give me candidates i'm trying to play
cupid here for you wonderful iconic
people here
oh she's in a relationship
oh
what about anita
it's a good friend of mine